la révision du procès d'omar raddad au
vu des nouvelles expertises l'avocat
général donne son feu vert le jardinier
marocain condamné en 94 pour le meurtre
de ghislaine marchal pourrait donc voir
son affaire jugée si la cour décide elle
rendra soin de sa décision le 25 juin
prochain valérie ermite blesse grenier
et alain location omar raddad à nouveau
devant la justice mais cette fois à sa
demande pour obtenir la révision de sa
condamnation
les contre expertises ordonnées par la
commission de révision constitue pelle
des faits nouveaux
pour l'avocat général cela ne fait pas
de doute les nouveaux experts se sont en
effet montrés incapables d'attribuer à
quiconque
l'inscription accusatrice omar m'a tuer
mais surtout en analysant les portes
ensanglanté deux adn masculins
différents ont été trouvés et ils
n'appartiennent pas à omar raddad
pour le parquet ces éléments étaient
inconnus lors du procès et justifie que
la cour de révision soit saisi ce que
demandé l'avocat d'omar raddad le
renvoie devant pour leur en vendre une
nouvelle juridiction ci pourra vérifier
tout ça nous disons pas qu'ici la preuve
de tête a porté de l'innocence
nous disons qu'ici là on doit apporter
des éléments qui suscitent en douter une
discussion la partie civile a réfuté
point par point ses doutes pour l'avocat
de la famille marchal la victime a
évidemment désigner un assassin les
portes ont été à l'audience de la cour
d'assises manipulé par tout le monde
dans des conditions telles que n'importe
qui appuient le laisser son adn
je reste convaincu qui a pu écrire cette
inscription avec le sang de la victime
s'est pas construit bloque la porte
c'est inconcevable c'est pas concevable
ça puisse être quelqu'un d'autre que la
victime elle-même elle sera discutée
omar raddad n'a pas dit mot ni dans la
salle d'audience me en dehors tout juste
s'est-il amusé de la cohue médiatique
qu'il engendrait le 25 juin prochain la
commission de révision dira si elle
estime nécessaire de saisir la cour de
révision qui seul peut décider de la
tenue d'un nouveau procès